lemagit non vers la fin de sa vie c'est
du félix leclerc que joseph roux l'ouémé
chanter comme ici au festival d'été de
québec alors qu'il avait 84 ans
[Musique]
il avait comme leclerc une voix de basse
et comme leclerc également avait décidé
de tenter sa chance en europe
joseph rouleau le petit gars de matane
réussi en 1956 à décrocher un contrat à
l'illustré maison d'opéra covent garden
à londres
c'est sûrement mon arrivée à kawenga
d'un homme qui a tout déclenché chatou
déclaré il restera à londres pendant
près de trente ans et jouera dans une
quarantaine de productions joseph
rouleau sera très en demande partout
dans le monde avec sa riche voix de
basse qui s'accordent si bien avec des
rôles dramatiques soit 10 du tueur par
exemple comme super utile dans rigoletto
nous des rois dans l'idée a par exemple
le dit ça dans boris godounov
[Musique]
son interprétation de boris godounov a
été marquante
il a même joué la pièce en russie là où
l'oeuvre a été créée après une longue
carrière internationale joseph rouleau a
eu le mal du pays à l'âge de 50 ans
j'avais dit moi je veux pas mourir
un radiateur je retournais chez nous et
c'est comme ça c'est à ce moment là
qu'il ait pris la décision de revenir
les part elles l'ont déjà par hasard se
trouve par ici
il revient au canada en 1981 devient
professeur à l'uqam et continue de
chanter surtout en amérique du nord
son implication dans le milieu musical
donnera naissance à l'opéra de montréal
et à la renaissance des jeunesses
musicales du canada qui ont permis à
tant de jeunes de se produire en
spectacle
[Musique]
quand on peut aider il n'y a rien de
plus satisfaisant moi je me couche le
soir puis j'ai mon dieu mais si beaucoup
on aurons nos bons depuis aidé j'ai pu
aider les messieurs joseph rouleau pour
avoir tant fait sur scène et en
coulisses joseph koulou a reçu tous les
honneurs pour son talent son travail
acharné et pour son humilité
quand les hommes vivront d'amour
il n'y aura plus de misère et comment
seront les beaux jours mais nous nous
serons mon bon c'est tellement beau jeu
magnifique ici louis fait les prix mais
radio-canada montréal